[Music]
hello everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to Fandango indie movie Guide coming to
you from the Toronto International Film
Festival
now the films that I mentioned that I
was looking forward to last week did
bigger films like mother the shape of
water battle of the sexes and three
billboards outside Irving Missouri have
all been at the top of my list of
favorites here at TIFF but what about
some of the smaller movies he should put
on your radar
[Music]
let's start with bodied which on the
surface is about rap battles but
underneath it's about racism privilege
fait quirkiness and who gets to say what
under the guise of entertainment it's by
Joseph Kahn a well known music video
director in fact he just did the video
clip for Taylor Swift's look what you
made me do and so he brings that unique
eye that visual energy to this movie
which has a lot to say and is so much
fun to watch
Velma is a Norwegian thriller by
director Yocum tria it's getting a lot
of comparisons to Stephen King's Carrie
and for good reason it's about a young
girl who suffers from powerful seizures
which unearth dangerous superpowers and
she is scared of herself and her own
feminine power it's intriguing it's
unsettling it really takes its time to
reveal and it's one that will stick in
your head for a long time afterwards 1%
is an Australian crime thriller that's
been described as Macbeth on motorbikes
it has a very Shakespearean seeming
story all about loyalty between real
family and loyalty between created
family in this case a bikie gang which
goes to war between the President and
the Vice President after the vice
president's brother gets in trouble
it is exciting it's violent its crude it
will not be for everyone but I really
enjoyed the cast I enjoyed the story and
I was engaged the whole time I feel like
it's something new and exciting from my
own home country of Australia
[Music]
you should also look out for a fantastic
woman which is a Chilean drama all about
a trans woman who has to deal with love
grief after suddenly losing her older
lover she also has to deal with a lot of
disdain and disrespect from the other
people involved in his life including
the police doctors but especially his
family it gives you a small insight into
the type of everyday obstacles that
trans people may have to overcome and
it's got a brilliant performance by the
lead actress Daniela
Vega call me by your name which is
directed by Luca Guadagnino based on a
book of the same name all about two guys
of the 1980s sometime somewhere in
northern Italy fall in love over summer
it is sensual it is tender it is
sensitive and completely heartbreaking I
saw it for a second time here it stars
armie hammer and Timothy Salome and it
is very very well done it's still one of
my favorite films of 2017 and the
florida project directed by Sean Baker
this film I caught in can and it was one
of my favorites there continues again to
stay at the top of my list of 2017 it's
all about the invisible homeless living
in Florida living just on the outskirts
of Disneyland the stories all told
through a child's perspective so even
though they're struggling with poverty
they don't quite realize it to them
these hotels are their own magical
kingdom it is very well done and very
well active particularly by the young
kids
and that's it for me from the Toronto
International Film Festival the sun's
coming out it is warming up so that
means I need to get back inside into the
dark and watch some more movies I'm
Alicia Malone you can follow me on
twitter at Alicia Malone and I'll see
you soon
[Music]